[Music]
and hydrating yourself with yourself
news bear grylls submitted by dan from
Jamali ah what you weren't even allowed
to come in you [ __ ] smuggling thief
mm-hmm okay a man swears by drinking a
pint of old year in a day to make him
feel amazing
I've heard this stall is it called urine
therapy or something you guys about this
Korea for a bit no I you're in Korea
yeah it was like this whole year in
facing in Korea don't even guy my first
job ever
that rumor so he was the guy that was
party remember he lacked around brown
dude oh yeah because I heard this rumor
and he was like the friendliest dude all
the time so when he sees you he always
wants to come up to you and talk to you
yeah his breath I always just kind of
like move like two feet away
I don't wanna spit on me but I don't
even know his breath smells just cuz all
these rumors on fences like yep I don't
open was Chuck Liddell one of these is
famous you have to see guys that we're
very open about their urine therapy like
they would drink it all the time you
[ __ ] sprayed his room it was one of
those guys are very open about it too
okay where'd the [ __ ] this even comes
from because I'm pretty sure that your
kidneys filter out all of the nutrients
and the electrolytes and everything so
the pee is just empty yes so what the
[ __ ] made them think because you know if
you do have an excess amount of vitamins
or whatever they're supposed to it's
just supposed to go out in your pee so I
think people are thinking like oh I'll
just get it back again yeah second time
around is so this guy here his name is
Fabian he's 37 -
as an interior designer in case you guys
are wondering yeah piss drinker already
thought interior designer in the future
boils in gets the toxins out that's a
tea bagging but it's not this is a very
specific that we've been hearing about
this like a lot of other people she
didn't want it to be her own yeah I know
y'all do that you ever read a headline
before you're like please please I'm
surprised that it's actually a black guy
because I would think Asian or white
yeah me too Joe when she turned that
laptop around I did not expect this to
happen it's more like guesses
you're like we don't have another
stereotyping he was in the UK so he said
that he was traveling a lot for work and
eating a lot of junk food and he just
started getting these really bad
stomachaches cuz you're eating junk food
you shit-faced pee mouth
I started getting stomachaches so I peed
in a cup and drank it and it felt so
much better it's like you went to the
doctor trying to figure out what was
going on with the stomach problems he
couldn't figure it out it's got more
like junk food so then he adopted a more
holistic diet and he started becoming a
fruitarian oh my god roots and he
noticed a difference
almost immediately doc cuz you're not
eating junk food anymore and also when
you're a fruitarian your fruit areas are
[ __ ] hilarious to me because they go
I have so much energy of you're eating
sugar all the time of course of course
they're gonna be high off of energy dude
me talking about the lady said that as
part of his research he stumbled across
drinking urine information about
drinking you would find that on a
fruitarian website yeah you're [ __ ]
fruitcake once you start eating all
fruits the next natural thing is
drinking piss and then having a Dookie
steak that's hot so then he's like I
have an open mind so I tried it a
dumbass mind it tasted a bit like like
these bitter and ale initially it was
quite strong but not
terrible taste he had no problem
finishing the glass fresh urine nice and
warm he so then he says it was about a
half hour later that he started to feel
amazing Oh a half hour that's how fast
it works you rock face yeah that's
probably adrenaline that was just like
he was bursting with energy and now we
drink another cup you would never go a
day without it I recommend it to anyone
he got a buzz off of it
this will strip in oh my god for me I
don't care what people do I'm
performance based right okay if you want
a drink or piss that's tight
what's your mild time if it beats
everyone else's and I can see that'd be
funny
i'ma drink piss too because all the
people that all the people have all
these extreme diets they're perform it's
always it makes me feel good or makes me
it's like the logic its cycle it's so
subjective I'm like what's your mile
time how much have you increased any of
your lives
are you that much body fat percentage
lower it's just always based off feel I
bet you yeah you know what cuz when you
think about it I bet you every time
after somebody completes a challenge on
fear factor they feel the same way I bet
they feel accomplished yeah thank God
it's over party challenges this Fool has
like a four-minute mile I'm like I'm
gonna start taking my own piss to that
mmm yes I think what he ended up doing
is he wanted the nutrients and stuff he
said that by aging his urine for one
month goes through a magnification just
drink apple cider vinegar homeboy and
that the benefits are made more potent
so he started fermenting his urine and
mason jars brought you this he'll write
it he'll label it with the date and then
leave it for 30 days and then drink it
after 30 days and so he waits until the
pH level reaches nine he's a connoisseur
now yes but see that's the same [ __ ]
with like tip we know
you know what the wild [ __ ] about this
it was like the whole thing with [ __ ]
uh you know like [ __ ] I wasn't called
the alkaline water right yeah they're
like oh it's gonna help balance your pH
you [ __ ] your body regulates that on its
own yeah that's how amazing your body is
whatever you put is not gonna be you
know amazing your body is you could be
500 pounds and still be alive that's
[ __ ] amazing saying it's adaptive
Texas area with pH level there nothing
foul 9.30 ninja bullet didn't use it my
god brand deal right now
great marking this was the only pool
that's pissing in are like [ __ ] no
because I put all your pots and pans up
piss on it no put your piss in us that
was true right what I would do is I
would just piss in a bottle and then ask
a chemist to figure out what that is and
then they're gonna say oh yes salt maybe
he was just salt deficient so he could
have done the same [ __ ] with Gatorade or
something because when it came out
well should you be somebody drinking pee
is the first question really helping my
worried about the color I'm worried
about the Pisgah you put it in a bottle
this I love the [ __ ] photographer the
photographer got is [ __ ] good it's
like sir can you all just braise it to
your mouth oh my god that is a funny
picture though like whenever someone's
looking at you while they're drinking
there are some crazy I wonder why people
like sometimes I guess and when it comes
to these things they just if somebody
brings up to them hey or they asked him
what about the actual facts of science
behind it they're like no no no that's
not it but why not why not look into
that like for example I had a
conversation with somebody yesterday
right there's a guy he was having like
his his stomach was getting distended
and whatever ended here we get a
distended stomach from a lot of gaseous
[ __ ] hello yeah blow and the reason why
was because of his diet he drank a lot
smoked a lot ate a lot of whatever right
so he can
red-meat and whatever out of his thing
he's just eating like vegetables and
fish oh good he goes you know what I
found out he goes red meat is bad for
you huh how about this how about you
stop drinking alcohol you stop smoking
you also started exercising and you
started eating cleaner that's nothing to
do with the red meat so for him in his
mind he just connected bad and here and
say he said I was like well how did you
come to that conclusion he goes well I
come to this Jamaican guy and the
Jamaican guy told me that when you eat
red meat right so that animal when it
dies it goes through pain and that pain
transfers into your body how's it hold
on a second Wow how the [ __ ] does that
make sense right
he goes look lots on a month of fish he
goes exactly so it's like logically that
makes sense ok I'll say that's like
saying you know what dude I want to live
forever
so I mean everything with preservatives
yeah [ __ ] forever what about a
lettuce when you tear it yes yeah it
actually here's a thing you know they
found out that plants communicate and
they feel yes and then they you know
that smell of fresh-cut grass that's
actually them communicating to like are
we that hurt yeah well they're clean you
yeah they're communicating that and then
they're communicating to like predator
animals to come in to help them out
blood it's grass blood it's kind of like
this hole yeah like like Evan Kuo
cutting my grass again I'm superior all
right I need to I need to eat the food
and I need to cut the grass I need to
play golf on those [ __ ] I'm
gonna cut them yeah like if uh if a
plant gets like full of aphids and [ __ ]
and then they're like bleeding and then
it excretes this smell and then ladybugs
come to come rescue it and it eats up
all the aphids and stuff let's go
communicate in Kodiak ecosystem yeah and
then they fight to sow their roots
underground they would come up and
they'll be like [ __ ] doing wrestling
yeah it was like slow-mo footage of them
fighting and taking over other plants
and we're drinking our own [ __ ] piss
our superior [ __ ] species you know
what if he feels fine doing it that's
cool but whatever he wants man piss boy
Darwinism you what he loves Waterworld
remember that movie I haven't peed in
that machine and it filters his piss and
he drinks it Oh watch that movie again
he'll probably watch that are Kelly's
sex day but he was like for delicious
yeah
oh lucky you thirsty how'd you get was
drinking okay I wonder if he'd be down
to drink other people's piss probably
not watch it be all judgmental and [ __ ]
[ __ ] no I'm not an animal
I mean maybe his piss is better because
he's drinking a lot of water a lot of
fruits and [ __ ] cuz you still want to
put a Terry in diet right that's my
sweet for him maybe oh my god dude the
man is getting high before works Tuesday
its combust taste but there's people
there's a lot of people that do this a
lot is in like more than one there's a
[ __ ] ton of people right there I think
this is a fing though it's like a like a
piss drinking culture my aunt
drink used to drink my cousin's piss why
why not her own because I was supposed
to be from a younger person you know
much cousin so it's not for how it's
just like she's it's like a elixir of
youth it's supposed to be like no she
would just ask him to pee in a cup in
the morning because they want the
morning piss and she would drink it why
every morning pisses the worst [ __ ]
piss all these people that do this
they're not thinking logically Kaba go
take a walk every day
wait was her really does she still do
that anymore do anymore cuz she passed
away I guess they did it cuz she thought
like there's a lecture of you throughout
the the pee that comes from a kid yeah
but the best way to do that that is for
her to bite the neck of her child is
suck the blood out of them that oh man I
love people
[Music]